[Música]
en esta región aislada del perú las
comunidades indígenas asháninkas se
encargan de comercializar su cacao el
objetivo es mejorar su nivel de vida y
proteger mejor la selva para agustín fue
un cambio de estilo de vida radical
al igual que los demás miembros de la
comunidad de kaman davis y antes era
cazador recolector ahora es productor de
cacao y está muy satisfecho con este
cambio
y empecé a cultivar cacao para poder
comprar ropa para mis esposas y juguetes
también pude comprar cuadernos para que
mis hijos vayan a la escuela libro que
te aparte él
hoy agustín se dedica exclusivamente al
cultivo de cacao y su éxito ha
convencido al resto de la comunidad de
400 familias
los ingresos son más altos más regulares
pero también están mejor distribuidos
entre todos los habitantes de kaman está
misión
el sistema es sostenible cada productor
no cultiva más de 3 hectáreas
el abandono progresivo de la casa
también contribuye a reducir la presión
sobre la fauna
una vida en armonía con el entorno en la
más pura tradición asháninka
qué área está que camina los asháninka
protegemos nuestro bosque los animales y
el agua para que nuestros niños sigan
beneficiándose en la bella e india
el problema hoy es que no quedan muchos
animales para alimentar a nuestras
familias tan es así que no hay
suficiente para la nueva generación la
orina amena que y es por eso que debemos
protegerlo que queden allí están aquí
quién está si estarían y paita perú
félix tu miembro de la etnia asháninka
que está detrás de este entusiasmo por
el cacao es un color bien ya está seco y
hasta se cuida para hallarla
ya llegó en el 7 por ciento de humedad
cuales potasio tienen que ser bien
seleccionados en 2010
félix todo creó la asociación que mito n
con el objetivo de que los asháninkas
recuperarán el control de su territorio
frente a las concesiones mineras la
deforestación y el narcotráfico
normalmente viaja 15 horas para visitar
a sus diversos productores en
comunidades remotas
así comprueba la calidad del cacao y
mantiene el vínculo con sus
colaboradores
pero la comercialización de chocolate
toma forma lejos de las hembras
esta es la provincia de satipo en el
departamento de junín es en esta ciudad
de 200.000 habitantes entre los andes y
el amazonas donde se encuentra la sede
de que vito n
aquí en félix o se encarga de su
asociación
empezó hace 11 años con 40 productores
hoy son más de 450
estamos digamos demostrando que si se
puede llegar muy lejos que en términos
anteriormente los asháninkas difícil de
tener una empresa no
que nadie podía creerlo que nosotros sí
estamos este
y dispuesto de llegar muy lejos
una docena de productos son fruto de la
cosecha de las comunidades indígenas
desde el chocolate negro hasta el
chocolate con leche pasando por la
mantequilla de cacao
todos estos productos están destinados
al mercado local e internacional
estamos en la opción de productos
terminados esto este polvo de cacao eso
van a ser enviados a australia y a rusia
no estos clientes que hemos conseguido
son pues a través de participaciones de
ferias eventos internacionales como
cualquier empresa lo realiza en dos
nuevos también realizamos este tipo de
trabajo para conseguir clientes y nuevos
clientes
asociación de productores que mito n
cuenta con el apoyo de varias
organizaciones internacionales como la
wwf
en 2010 recibió el premio ecuatorial
concedido por naciones unidas para
proyectos de desarrollo económico
sostenible
gracias al cacao los asháninkas son
autosuficientes y preservan el medio
ambiente para las generaciones futuras